[Musique]
oui bienvenue par l'auteur m6 mélissa
mollen depuis cette semaine j'ai aussi
que vous savez que je sais que vous
savez que je veux parler du 21 juin
journée de célébration des communautés
autochtones à travers le canada
pour moi c'est une journée pour faire un
bilan regardez ce qui est des moments de
résistance incroyable pour nos
communautés à travers le canada
travaille même l'amérique je pense ne
serait ce qu'au fait qu'on est encore
aujourd'hui en train de parler de deuil
si chaque individu auquel la tournée de
l'impact ce à l'heure du tremblement de
terre que ça l'a amené au milieu des
services de santé qui sont donnés aux
communautés autochtones
je pense notamment aussi à tous les
protecteurs du territoire qui sont
encore aujourd'hui peu importe la
direction en train de voir économiques
sont ravageurs et tu vas n'est pas si
l'activité de leur communauté
je pense beaucoup à faire et quid par
exemple présentement étude combinée
entre autochtones et allochtones peau
empêcher que certaines des plus belles
forêts anciennes se fasse couper ou non
d'une économie qui n'est pas consistante
avec nos besoins du futur énormément de
choses sont mis de l'avant les projets
autour de la loi 101 où l'on voudrait
quand même voir des langues autochtones
être reconnus comme étant des langues
officielles la même manière que le
français et l'anglais le sont beaucoup
d'enjeu encore sur la table mais est ce
que le 21 juin 2021 21 juin 2021 ça fait
beaucoup de 2 2 1 2 et 2 2 est ce que
c'est une raison de célébrer et moi mon
bilan personnel c'est que oui je
célébrer le fait qu' on est encore mais
malgré le fait qu'on est encore dans la
résistance
on est dans l'existence on est encore
ici on clame encore notre droit se faire
entendre en tant que personnes qui
étaient là ont promis que personne
questions qui ont été la bn justement du
pays on nomme aujourd'hui le canada et
je pense qu'il ya quelque chose à
célébrer cas il ya quelques années le 21
juin avait aucune résonance pour la
population grand complet et aujourd'hui
j'ai bien sûr une célébration non
seulement nationale mais si tu célébrer
son espace la population autochtone
uniquement de plus en plus d'allochtones
célèbre le 21 juin
de la même manière que nous avons
célébré le 24 juin ou le 1er juillet
pendant les dernières décennies à notre
manière avec notre propre savoir une eau
propre raison de le faire mais je pense
que d'être encore ici aujourd'hui
d'avoir de plus en plus nos enjeux
entente d'avoir de plus en plus une
réaction face aux injustices
je pense particulièrement aux 215
enfants
on a trouvé un camelot et qui ont fait
en sorte que maintenant de plus en plus
de gens raisonnent face au fait ya
encore des enfants pourront retrouver
leur chemin de leurs maisons de leurs
familles dont ont été enterrés je
demande et vous n'avez l'eau familiaux
comme des objectifs voudrait avoir ses
ancêtres pour ses enfants et avec une
réaction qui se produit que je ne
réponde plus voir et quelques amis ya de
plus en plus une interaction justement
des artistes actuels en dehors des
moments qui sont habituellement
réservées aux communautés attaque donne
donc célébrée le 21 juin oui et je pense
qu'on va séduire aussi le 24 juin pour
la présence autochtone le 1er juillet
pour des raisons qu'on comprend cette
année - c'est vrai d'une façon très
différents mais qui a deux fois pour une
progression et surtout de quoi voir une
célébration faut uniquement de nous
mêmes pour nous mêmes mais de la
communauté a menti pour justement les
communautés autochtones dont je souhaite
un bon 21 juin bon ceci dit ce bon début
de l'été puis belle journée de l'année
et j'espère que vous continuerez à
suivre espace autochtone à partager nos
vidéos
envoyez vos questions parce que
justement c'est l'interaction entre nos
peuples qui font que le discours a
continué d'avancer et d'évoluer